have a soul my name is Samuel Leeds and
one of the strategies that I've been
teaching doing advocating over the last
couple of years is rent to serviced
accommodation now serviced accommodation
is when you turn a property basically
into a hotel when you rent it out by the
night on booking.com on Airbnb and you
get a lot more rent for a property now
the problem with service accommodation
right now is that booking com aren't
taking bookings and no one can leave
their house so the hotel industry as a
whole in fact most businesses as a whole
have been hit really hard so some of my
students some of my followers are in
situations now where they've got rent to
rent properties they're paying a
landlord let's say a thousand pound a
month and then they're using the
property and they're listing it on
Airbnb booking comm and they're making
three thousand pound a month giving a
thousand pounds a month to the landlord
a thousand pounds of mother's going on
expenses and they're being left with a
thousand pounds a month profit wasn't
that fantastic isn't it a great business
model absolutely however what about
right now if you're having to give a
thousand pound to the landlord but
you're not renting it out because you
can't and then what's happening is
you're actually making a loss every
single month if you're in that situation
right now there's four things that
potentially you could do or could
consider first thing you can potentially
do is you could hands the keys back to
the landlord and say I quit now that
option I wouldn't advise unless you
absolutely have to do that because
number one is you're letting down the
landlord when you're breaking your
agreement and I don't know exactly what
your contract and what the clauses are
there could be a break clause in there
which you're wondering whether to
exercise or not but the second reason is
because this is gonna get better this is
gonna get better right now people can't
leave the houses and can't stay at your
service - combination unit but that's
because they're not allowed to leave the
house and all businesses are suffering a
little bit at the moment so I wouldn't
advise doing that unless you are stuff
if you're stuck and you haven't got the
money to pay the landlord I wouldn't
judge you for handing back the keys the
second thing you could do is you can
renegotiate with the landlord this is a
more preferred option than just handing
back the keys so if you're if you're
losing money and you're paying a
thousand pound to the landlord and you
haven't got any guests in the house and
you're stuffed and you're
wiggling in your outer pocket why not
just say to the landlord listen it's a
really difficult time at the moment
tenants aren't paying tenants can't be
evicted booking commies is not taking
bookings I know that a lot of landlords
are taking three-month holiday period on
their mortgage companies during this
lockdown period I know I'm paying you a
thousand pounds a month but can we look
potentially if we negotiate it can we
can I just pay you half that or can I
have a little breathing space it's
surprising how nice and understanding
most people are in this current
situation so that's a really good option
try and renegotiate be upfront
communication is usually the key to a
good business and also to success just
generally so communicate with the
landlord telling you situation and see
if you can work something out step 3 is
you can just ride the storm and you can
say you know what I'm not making as much
money as I was I've been here
financially I might be down financially
over the next couple months but over the
year I'm still gonna make a lot of money
and I'm just going to look at this as a
long-term business I'm gonna ride the
storm and I'm just going to take a hit
short time short term that's a
reasonable option if you can afford to
do that and you're not you're not down
massively financially I do think that's
a reasonable option especially as things
are gonna get better in my opinion very
soon option number four which is what
most of my students are doing is they're
doing a combination of three and four
and option number four is just try and
be really creative and try and see if
you can get bookings with key workers I
mean some of my students have turned
their Airbnb units into self-isolation
units they've given them to the NHS and
they've found key workers so even if
it's a case if you're not going to
making a lot of profit but you're just
going to be kind of tip breaking even at
least that's better than nothing so be
creative remarket think how can I
actually get people in my property that
aren't tourists that aren't on holiday
because there are still people there are
contractors there are builders there are
nurses that are needing short-term
accommodation to work so those are the
four options if you can think of any
other options comment below and let me
know what you think if you've got a
serviced accommodation property or
you've got a serviced accommodation unit
I'd love to hear what
how you dealing with his time so comment
below and let me know what you're doing
also I just want to say listen we will
get through this this is a short-term
problem the lockdown is gonna end soon
and things are gonna pick up this is not
the end of the world this is not a
crisis that's gonna be bigger than us
we're bigger than the crisis I really
wholeheartedly believe that we're gonna
get through this so be encouraged stay
positive stay healthy and I'll see you
on the next video